con los pies inflamados y el estómago
vacío llegaron los miles de emigrantes a
pernoctar en huixtla 50 kilómetros al
norte de tapachula la ciudad fronteriza
del sur de méxico donde nunca más
esperan volver
pero los niños a las 5 de la mañana ayer
los niños estaban vomitando sada únicas
50 km que ésta pedía y para acá para que
no vengan a darle té
una tarjeta de paso prácticamente un
salvoconducto porque no fue ni una bis
este es el documento que a franklin como
a miles de emigrantes le negaron en
tapachula y sin el cual quedan expuestos
a ser capturados y deportados por los
agentes de inmigración
ahora en huixtla las oficinas de aduana
están desbordadas y día tras día se ven
aglomeraciones de personas desesperadas
por obtener el documento peor aún para
los migrantes haitianos y africanos que
no dominan el español actuamos con sala
andrés de cielo para pie salimos hace
tres meses de áfrica y llevamos una
semana aquí esperando el documento y por
fin hoy nos lo entregaron queremos ir a
eeuu
amamos eeuu y vamos para allá a hacer
nuestra vida fácil abajo para ti fer en
otro fila baja
cae la noche y se sublevan los ánimos
hay malestar en el ambiente
todavía son entre 7000 y 8000 los
migrantes de la caravana que aguardan el
pase migratorio para gozar de 30 días de
legalidad y aún así es un tiempo
insuficiente para los que no tienen
dinero en el bolsillo porque tendrán que
trabajar para conseguir los costosos
boletos de autobús que los transporten
hasta su destino final a más de 2.200
kilómetros la frontera sur de eeuu